58 jours c'est le délai moyen en France
pour obtenir un rendez-vous pour
renouveler ses papiers d'identité un
temps d'attente jugé trop long alors
pour essayer d'y remédier le
gouvernement annoncé en début d'année
l'ouverture de 500 nouveaux guichets
partout en France les communes qui
joueront le jeu seront accompagnés
financièrement un appel à l'aide
notamment entendu par la mairie de
Manthelan dans le Loir Turquie
toute l'équipe est réunie pour ce
nouveau projet d'ici quelques mois il
sera possible de faire une demande de
passeport ou de carte d'identité à la
mairie de Manthelan une annonce qu'il
n'est pas passée inaperçue il y a une
parution dans le journal et depuis on a
des appels chaque jour pour nous
demander la date d'ouverture pour déjà
prendre des rendez-vous donc on sait
qu'on est attendu vraiment sur ce
nouveau service date prévue des premiers
créneaux à la mi-septembre un travail
collectif et un investissement qui
permettra aussi l'ouverture d'un nouveau
poste à mi-temps aujourd'hui ensuite
Touraine seuls deux communes peuvent
fournir des documents d'identité et pour
Bernard piperault le maire de Manthelan
c'est bien trop peu on est tout petit
mais on nous a dit est-ce que vous
acceptez et on a dit oui on a pensé que
c'était un service tout simplement pour
la population et la ruralité si on veut
la faire vivre c'est par des opérations
comme ça c'est pour ça qu'on y va
à 10 km de là Ligueil ici la mairie a
refusé l'installation d'un dispositif de
recueil en cause des services déjà
nombreux sur la commune et une aide
initiale de l'état de 9000 euros jugé
insuffisante alors une nouvelle
prestation délocalisée dans une ville
voisine c'est du gagnant-gagnant pour
faire vivre le territoire il faut aussi
que des communes de relatives
importantes puissent prendre leur part à
la répartition de services d'état c'est
vraiment un service qui aurait été payé
par les contribuables de Ligueil pour
une infime minorité de ceux qui payent
les impôts ici un futur service à
mantelant très attendu parce que de mon
côté j'ai essayé d'avoir un créneau sur
le site rendez-vous passeport.gouv.fr
c'est un site qui permet de voir les
prochains rendez-vous disponibles autour
de soi donc j'ai testé avec plusieurs
villes en Indre-et-Loire et Loir-et-Cher
avec un périmètre de 60 km autour de la
ville résultat le rendez-vous le plus
tôt que j'ai pu avoir c'est le 7 juin à
la mairie de Melun sur Yevre c'est à
plus d'une heure et demie de route de
Tours